hello everyone this is Abbot I'm the
host and the teaching assistant for
today's webinar on a white cloud
computing certification makes sense if
you are able to hear me please go ahead
and give me a hi hello on the chat
window so that we can get started
all right everyone we have our trainer
Bob Don who'll be starting the session
or conducting his presentation for the
first 45 minutes so I would like to keep
you all posted you everyone will be on
mute so a couple of ground rules of the
session you have any question please go
ahead and put the question in the chat
window however I request you all to
reserve your questions so that we will
have the 15 minutes question and answer
at the end of the session or at end of
the art so basically we'll go for 45
minutes of the session without any any
interruption the 15 minutes we will
reserved for the question and answers
from our trainer or will be willing to
answer all your questions so without any
further ado I would like to introduce
you to our trainer abook Don so he's one
of the authorized trainer for Google
cloud platform so he has conducted a lot
of trainings in-person or virtual like
like you see the slide over 200 students
wherein he has trained to develop the
great product on Google cloud platform
as well he's been a yeast or he he has
more certificates then I can talk about
so overall six plus years of experience
in developing products on Google cloud
platform more than more than daaad I can
talk about those students okay and about
his uh
roles or his positions he has he has
been a developer a trainer and twopenny
are and he also has a start-up in
romania where in our he's been
developing the apps on Google platform
so without any further ado I'll go ahead
and unmute our trainer hi book Don you
can go ahead your mic is open hello
everyone and welcome to today's session
I hope everyone can hear me fine
a year's book Don I hear you so let me
ask the participants I'll be able to
hear our trainer is it loud and clear
okay okay great
so hello everyone and welcome to today's
session we are going to talk about why
cloud computing certifications make
sense I for one I am a cloud computer
have a certification in cloud computing
and it has been great for me so I'm
going to talk about why this is good
also for you and why you should all try
to get a certificate and here is not
just about the money is why would you
want to go on and learn about new stuff
and get certified in something like
cloud computing okay so the agenda for
today we are going to talk about how IT
industry evolves over time
why do righty company use the cloud in
the first place so what was what were
the problems that IT companies tried to
solve by using the cloud what are
Vantage's of cloud versus on-premise
infrastructure and do companies actually
look for cloud ready people or they just
prefer getting them without any
knowledge okay so why MIT industry has
evolved a great lot so in the early days
the first personal computer was a huge
one and it was costing like a fortune
since then I got a lot smaller and a lot
cheaper so if
one starting getting computer and may at
the moment almost all people have a
personal computer at home or at work in
in somewhere between 1990 and 2000 there
was a booming personal computers and
everyone was buying no personal computer
for either their workplace or their home
news so it was a really big boom and a
lot of companies have evolved a great
lot because of these some more some like
a Microsoft and Apple they have IBM also
so they have developed a great deal of
improvements on those computers so that
we can take advantage of the compute
power ok after personal computers
laptops came because they were easier to
carry around and there were more compact
you didn't have so you could move around
so a lot of more people have adopted
them especially salespeople and
different companies that needed moving
around not not those that were pinned to
a desk nowadays we have a ton of
Internet connected devices so here are
just a few things like smart phones
smart watches smart houses smart cars or
so they're driving cars Internet of
Things they are a lot of devices that
are getting more and more connected to
the internet and connected to each other
and this means there is a lot more
technical power and a lot more
processing power this means also that we
need a lot more software to
run on these devices okay so all devices
that are connected to internet actually
connect to a server either web server or
back-end for some application and all
the devices generate a lot of data I
don't mean here just sensors or things
like that people talk to each other we
have things like Facebook where you post
your pictures and you get the feedback
comments so there is a lot of data
generated and people and IT companies
call the data as virtual money so well
for more data you have more money you
have and losing data or losing is
equivalent to losing money for instance
now there was a trend for a couple for
about ten years has a head start at
about ten years ago so 90% of the
world's data was generated in the last
two years and it's a trend that is keep
on going on so this means each year a
lot more that data is developing and we
get a lot more data to be processed and
in terms we need more software and
better software faster software and more
IT people to handle that increased data
and data intake we also need more
servers to process the data and more and
more specialized software that analyzes
and makes minute by minute estimates on
how to promote a certain product or how
to act on that particular data i I'm not
talking all only about analytics and
customer sales but those are one of the
most important
because if you know what to focus on you
can make a lot more money than if you
don't know so a lot more specialized
software is needed and a lot more things
so custom software is needed and
basically you need more IT people
because you need more applications to
run and collect data and generate
reports so that companies can grow so as
digital dominates and work force all
require you to know computer skills new
skills are needed also for IT teams
compete here we are we're not just
talking about how to install a mail or
how to use a word document we are
talking about how to process lots of
lots of data how to create an
application how to extend that
application how to configure database
virtual machine or other things now
there is a big trend in machine learning
that actually takes a lot of data as
intake and you need specialized people
just for that role technology also
evolves very rapidly and changing
changes and challenges employees on how
to and what to learn next and I'm not
just talking about new languages like
Java and Python and go and things like
that but I'm also talking about things
like do I need to learn about the cloud
do I need to learn about infrastructure
or databases what kind of databases how
to develop a product that is fault
tolerant and can handle
the demands of today because now you can
grow your business from zero to 100
million users really quickly and there
are a lot of companies that do just that
for instance snapchat and a lot more can
Academy simply learn there are a lot of
companies that really developed in a
short amount of time and have grown a
user base really rapidly so all these
changes really challenges employees to
think outside the box and think on how
can they grow and develop better
products for their companies and
innovate on those products in order for
them to be more productive and handle
more more data and generate more money
for the company and in terms for
themselves because everyone knows if
your company strives you will also
strive with it and you can grow and get
better information and get different
tweets and different bonuses at the end
of a year and things like that so the
more you help your company the more it
will be better for your you and your
company so one third of IT leaders keep
still Quint with emerging technology and
trends because they know if they don't
catch a wave of changes they will be
left behind for instance I was reading
an article about Intel that focused only
or mostly on laptop processors and not
so much on mobile and low-power devices
so they really got a little bit behind
on this processor market so they had to
lay off a lot of IT people from their
company because they couldn't be the
best and they couldn't be there okay
so a lot of IT company that are leaders
in the market now they all strive to
develop the new thing and use the latest
technologies because on the one hand you
can motivate an employee by giving him
something new to work on and something
new to learn and enable him enabling him
to make a difference make the next app
that really is really successful so they
are trying to be on the very edge and
useful latest technologies because in
terms they know that they are not just
helping themself they are also helping
their employees also top performing
companies are you know investing a lot
in training and development so they are
training their employees to learn the
new technologies and to be very very to
be on the very edge and be able to have
up-to-date stuff that will be able to
produce better and better
applications that can can really impart
their user base and in terms their
enumeration and a growth of a company
they are also using technologies like
cloud to fuel a kind of a gap that old
old technologies didn't enable so
they really turning to the cloud to help
support increasing development demands
and increasing user base the net demands
also
to get to be able to get applications to
get global and not just local because
when you develop on a local scale and
you do all the infrastructure on premise
in a specialized custom data center in
your country for instance then most
likely you will be missing out on a lot
of users and that's why IT companies try
to migrate the cloud because cloud
enables you to create application that
spans the whole globe and be able to do
something like a global application like
Google search and other applications
that are out there and a lot of people
use also close services allow companies
to offload data management back-end
development and even design so their
that their IT people can focus on
innovation and create better apps that
do a lot more than of the company that
is competing with them and this way
everyone grows because if I do something
really great and somebody else sees me
and say okay I need to do even better
than him and then then all the
applications grow and the users are
feeling happy because they are getting
better they are getting applications
that are better and better and they
respond to date Bey demands
80% of people that are developing in the
cloud say that they are working
primarily on projects that will
transform their businesses and that they
will basically be the next Apple or the
next Google or the next simple learn and
be the company that will manage to get
global and attract a whole whole bunch
of user base and a lot of investment and
basically a lot of money also developing
in mcleod require less people to manage
infrastructure than doing this on
premise I was talking to somebody that
was actually doing things on premise and
he he was the manager for the meaning
that data center that he was operating
and he told me that he had a hundred
people just to manage infrastructure so
just for changing hard drives changing
RAM adding new computers repairing
ventilation system doing things like AC
interruptions or thunderstorm repairs
copying files from Warren hard drive to
another when the first one broke and
things like that so there were wasting
100 people manpower on just doing
maintenance on a piece of hardware that
you don't have to do when you are moving
to a cloud so cloud really helps you
develop better apps because you have
more time to focus on web apps and less
to focus on the actual infrastructure
that is behind that and those apps
so do IT company use the cloud well this
is a chart for Europe so how much how
many companies in Europe are using the
cloud in in 2014 so this is a chart from
2014 and some of them have even over
some country even have over 50 50
percent of the companies using cloud at
the moment so this is a growing trend so
since then all these numbers have grown
but cloud is still something that is
developing so it's near not full there
as you can see where average is 19% for
Europe this means that there is still a
lot a lot of place for improvement and a
lot of place for companies to grow but
for these they need people that are
skilled and people IT people that know
what they are doing and how to do apps
in the cloud in the modern way using new
technologies like using some big
analytics things or knowing machine
learning or using a database that can
span to a billion users and things like
that so for for these companies to
actually grow and develop and get them
more get more and more involved in cloud
you need first IT people that actually
know cloud and how to use it how to
develop great apps and then they will
adopt because we will see now we have a
special slide for this it's a lot
cheaper and a lot error-prone and
it's a lot better to do it this way than
in the old-fashioned way okay so there
are actually two kinds of cloud at the
moment one is called a public cloud and
one is called private cloud
well actual difference between public
and private clouds is a big difference
and some companies before private cloud
some companies before public cloud but
definitely both types of companies start
preferring cloud then bring it on
premise the pub a public cloud is
basically when you have you just say
okay I need to rent five virtual
machines I don't care how you give them
to me I just need them and I will pay
them out an hourly rate and say okay I
just need I don't know a thousand
virtual machines for five hours now and
tonight I'm not going to need them maybe
tomorrow I'm going to need them and next
month and that's it and we're great
thing about this is it's a great money
saver because since you are renting
infrastructure and not actually buying
it you can rent a lot more
infrastructure to be able to serve your
needs and only rent it when you actually
need it and maybe not in the night hours
or in the weekend when you are not
working so you don't have to buy
expensive computers and expensive
network infrastructure and a lot of hard
drives and all those things that are
actually needed in order for you to run
you just rented by the hour exactly when
you need it and for how much time you
need
the private cloud is a little bit
different because you still buy your own
hardware and you just ship it to
somebody and they will take care of
managing so you don't have to manage
infrastructure yourself you just ship it
to somebody and they will manage the
infrastructure but network management
but cable system the ventilation will
power that those computer need and
things like that but it's still your own
hardware and from what I know most big
companies
opt for this kind of cloud so these are
the two types of cloud that are now the
next type of cloud that a few big
companies like Google have they are
driving for is the one ones that you
don't even have to worry about
infrastructure you just worry about your
application and you just say I I give
you the DS application run it for me I
don't know I don't care how I just want
you to run this application on a global
scale okay so this these are the top
industries that cloud has gotten into so
information and communication is one of
them the highest with a 45 percent the
professional scientific and is not
technical activities its second after we
25 27 % also real
state administrative and support
services electric gas stream and air
conditioning water and accommodation
also have a great number at the end of a
chart are things like construction that
still use cloud for different activities
but still rely on things like on premise
for a great part of their activity okay
so what are we advantages of cloud
versus on-premise so in all days there
was a standalone software where you had
to write a piece of software and burn
into a CD and ship it to your customer
the customer took the that CD and
install it into his personal computer
but updates were really hard to do
because you you couldn't actually update
it because you weren't connected to
internet or application couldn't connect
to the internet or there was no way for
you to update that piece of software so
every six months or every one year that
company was shipping another CD with the
updated version of a same software where
he introduced new bugs but fixed or some
of the old bugs and it was really slow
because it took you like six months or a
year or more to get a new version of the
same app into your users hands so
innovation was really slow you couldn't
do much of things like a bee testing
where you couldn't test a new feature on
a subset of users you just have to make
sure your application was as Christine
as possible and you just ship it and
hope for the best
after that clients server software
started to show where you had still a CD
that was shipped and installed on to
your computer but that application was
talking to a back-end server somewhere
on your premise and you were able to do
something like shared application where
multiple users can use the same
application and they can share the same
data and you didn't have to use flash
drives or CDs to move data around the
office between your users it was a step
forward because you could have multiple
users using the same software the same
database and all populating the same
information but it was still slow
because you still had to do updates on
that server and there were slow and you
had to buy a lot of infrastructure for
that
after that you they moved the server to
somewhere that was publicly accessible
like somewhere someone that was
providing some sort of back-end service
or that could host your application so
the era of web server software started
to merge and you could say okay I need
somewhere general that can be accessed
for the same software as before but the
location wasn't really important anymore
because you could be somewhere else and
still access it still access the data
through internet since more and more
devices came along
those kind of applications didn't stand
a chance
because the more users you have more
strain your application server will be
and at one point when you can't handle
those traffic your application server
will just die so people started going to
cloud 2 and software as a service so
they can manage bigger and faster
infrastructure that could handle more
and more workloads also that could
empower you to go at a global scale
because clouds can be global and it is
it is supposed to be global
so my user from Europe don't have to go
all the way to America to get a piece of
software and add 300 milliseconds to
each request and basically get a lower a
lower performing application ok so what
do you have to do in order for you to do
something on-premise so on premise when
you had to get something like a server
and router and the land land switch and
the same switch different types of
storages for our hiving you also had to
buy tape storage because it's cheaper
also you had to get a UPS because you
needed power and in case the UPS ran out
of juice you need
power generator because you have to
think about the worst so you have to
think about something like the internet
failing so we needed to buy two Internet
connections you need to think about the
power failing so you need to get a power
generator a power generator usually
makes a lot of noise so if you have
developers in the same room as all those
servers and switches and power
generators they will go home as zombies
because they will hear a lot of
background noise all the time so this
was just to be able to do in one
location but as any big company knows
you cannot rely on just one location so
you have to have multiple locations so
multiply all of those equipments by two
or three or even four or five so if the
whole infrastructure for just hosting
one or application costed you something
like $50,000 or even more somewhere
about a hundred to five hundred thousand
dollars for one location when you
multiply that by more locations you
ended up spending millions and millions
of dollars on just being able to serve a
number of users and if this didn't scale
because every time your users killed you
had to scale your infrastructure
this means more Hardware more cost and
more people to manage all of that so
what are the advantages of cloud there's
premise so one is separation of
responsibilities so where when you are
doing these on-premise various
possibilities on all on
all on you so you had to take care of
networking storage servers
virtualization operating system
middleware runtime they talked occasions
libraries and everything in between so
there was a lot of things that I think
mighty people had to do in order for
your application to run and be
productive in the world of
infrastructure as a service where you
rent virtual machines although the
networking storage use servers and
visualization are taking care for you by
the cloud provider you don't have to do
that yourself so a lot less IT people
required in your company but you still
have to take care of your OS middleware
runtime data and application when you're
looking at platform as a service you
don't even have to worry about the OS
middleware and runtime because the cloud
provider does it for you so you only
have to focus on the data and
application that you are building so
here on the platform as a service you
can really innovate because it enables
you to only focus on application and the
data that you can collect from your
users and from your applications for
instance I I myself I am a developer and
I opted for a platform as a service
whenever I can and I develop I developed
a lot of apps in my days I'm still
developing apps each day and the
platform as-a-service really enabled me
to be able to do a lot of things that I
didn't think you were possible because
every day I come to work and I start
doing new feature and you
that does something great for my users
that will bring me more money for a
company I work for and more users and
but a greater satisfaction because what
I did today was used and helped users so
I go to work and do this new feature
that I was building and just deployed to
the platform I am using and I don't have
to worry and about configurations and OS
and security patches that needed to be
applied to some weird library that I
didn't even know about that OS was using
also about the runtime for middleware
and all those things so really it
enables me to be able to deploy new
versions a few times a day sometimes
some sometimes once a day sometimes once
a week depending on the feature I am
developing but each and every day I go
to work and focus on vacation and
developing new and great features into
those applications rather than focusing
on doing maintenance and doing security
updates on different applications that I
actually don't even need to care about
so all these ends up when into an a
software-as-a-service where you do this
is what you usually build so you build
some piece of software that you give
your users to be able to use and use
develop it and your users don't need to
know anything about that application
except how it works and what's a new
great features
it has okay so they don't need to care
they don't need to care about any of how
it was made what was the language it was
made how its jails how it does data
disaster II how is storing the data we
user doesn't need to know of that it
just needs to know how to use the
application and to work with application
so do companies actually look for IT
ready people well there is a lot of
demand for IT people especially people
that know cloud and know how to work
with a lot of data and to build great
applications and that are up to date
with the latest technologies with the
latest software where latest trends in
technology and really there are looking
for people that drive themselves on
learning new things each day and
improving their applications and
developing great new features for the
application they are working on so
technologies change and IQ people need
to be there to learn about those and
need to be up-to-date on what changes
and how and how this new feature that
the cloud provider dawn can't help
application you are building and what
great services you can use in order for
you to be more productive and develop
better and better apps so how do you
prove to your companies that you
actually know those technologies well
the easiest and best way to do that is
by providing the certification so this
way you say
you leave of a problem of is that IT guy
actually knows what here he is talking
about or he just read an article
somewhere and he's real he's good at
people skills and can work around
different difficult questions so
certifications are something that cloud
companies started adopting and they are
a great way for you to say okay I really
and actually know this technology and a
lot of companies and nowadays only look
at certifications when they hire new
people because it's easier for them to
say okay this is a nighty guy that
actually knows what he's talking about
or he's somebody that just heard about
that technology and he just says I know
that energy nowadays it's hard for you
to prove that you actually know
something the easiest way is to just
show a diploma or a certification and
say I know what I'm doing and you have
to trust me because I was certified by a
specialized company into this technology
and you have to trust me because I know
better than you that this is the way of
doing things now okay so this was my
presentation hope you enjoyed it and we
are now opening the Q&A section so I see
that we have a few questions in the
question who live so
go on with the first question for
someone waiting to learn cloud why
should they choose to run Google cloud
over AWS Azure so for career development
so I for one I'm somebody dad started
with Google a lot of years ago so I
started with them about six years ago
when no one knew that Google was
actually a cloud provider their
marketing skills on the cloud thing were
lacking a lot so they didn't know how to
promote the great things that they were
building I am actually really happy with
my choice so I either one chose Google
cloud over AWS in Azure and I'm really
happy with my choice big choice because
they are focusing a lot on the cloud and
recently they really invested a huge
amounts of money in both developing
infrastructure for applications that I
am building and other developers are
building but also for providing more and
more tools and API is that we can use as
developers and be able to create better
and better applications that scale more
and more more easily at a better price
so they are doing a lot of innovation in
both infrastructure and software and
they have shown it in the past years
about 15 to 20 years since they started
so they are developing the
infrastructure for themselves and they
are letting us be developers use that
infrastructure now in order to build
applications
so I'm really happy with how Google
Cloud is developing and how Google how
revision of Google is because their main
focus is on innovation and bringing
better and better software to the table
so I think eyes like me can really
thrive so let's go on to the next
question so what are all Google cloud
certification can one do with no coding
skills so at the moment with no coding
skills they have certifications for
g-suit or old liked it was called Google
Apps for work so those are without work
coding skills coding is somehow weird
term because for instance a business
intelligence guy can also do his work
using google cloud and he is required to
have some kind of skills to be able to
write something like a sequel query to
get to process the data he is looking at
so yes they for some things you require
some coding skills for some things you
require less coding skills and for some
things are just coding so just for
developers or sis admins or big data
specialists or machine learning
specialists but there are certifications
that you can take and really help your
company without knowing how coding aim
real term is because actually in the old
days when you are doing excels and wards
they were considered something like a
coding skills or technical skills now
everyone is supposed to know Excel and
word and be able to do something like
charts and filtering and sorting and
things like that so depending on the
wording of coding there are
certifications that you can do without
coding how can experience IT leaders
seniors senior leaders benefit from
learning google cloud well if you are by
a specialist in your company and you
want great now you want to move your
company into a new level
google cloud offers a lot of things
including migration from on-premise to
cloud how best practices or how to build
applications how to handle millions of
users how to handle increasing amounts
of data how to process different things
fast so that your company can actually
use the information that it's generating
so as an IT specialist or leader in your
company the best thing to do is push
your users to not your user so your
teammates to learn a new way of doing
software and a new way of running into
the cloud or in good and in a better way
then you could do it in the past so next
question are is what are the best
certifications for mcleod so at the
moment there are a few certifications
that you can do for the cloud you can
depending on the IT guy you are speaking
to there is a certification for system
operations where you have to manage
virtual machines persistent beast
networks firewall rules operating
systems web servers or different things
that you installed on those servers
containers that are new thing on the
market now on the other hand if you are
developer you can learn how to use
something that I for one before that is
a platform as a service where you just
learn how to use the database well the
underlying platform that you are using
and really develop greater and greater
apps that are using different api's and
interconnect with different tools and
basically giving you what edge when
developing an app there is also a lot of
focus now on Big Data and machine
learning sometimes you hear them in the
same sentence something like big data
and machine learning sometimes you hear
them separately because you can analyze
data without machine learning but you
can't do machine learning without a lot
of data so those are the new things on
the market now because like I said
earlier 90% of the data was generated in
the last two years so if this is a
ongoing trend in about five to ten years
we will have a lot more data so you
actually need specialized software to
make predictions and do things like
analysis on that increasing data
let's go on with the next question is
Google cloud connected to over Android
operating system such that it can be
turned on and off and operate
transparently without programming these
features independently is similar to
Apple cloud so the Google cloud is not
just for Android actually you can do a
lot of apps and a lot of things on
Google cloud that are not related to
Android or iOS or web applications so I
was reading about a company that was
doing transcoding for senior Hollywood
films for Hollywood movies on virtual
machines in Google cloud and they were
using like 10,000 virtual machines for a
short amount of times to process big
scenes with a lot of special effects and
a lot of blowing up and shooting and a
lot of falling and things like that so
actually you can use blue cloud for
things other than an Android and yes you
can use Google Cloud and turn it on and
off whenever you want like I said before
this company was using something like
10,000 virtual machines for 30 minutes
every time that designer needed it too
so every time I as a designer was
modifying something to a scene I just
ran a script that was bringing up 10,000
virtual machines the did the rendering
gave me a find a picture and I said okay
oops I forgot some little thing there
and this was this was for all their
designers and each of their designers
was able to bring that much
infrastructure on and off whenever he
needed it so yes you can turn on and off
anything in Google Cloud depending on
your business and
how you are doing things so the next
question is how certain security fits
into cloud can you recommend any base
certificate applications for it so
depending on exactly what you are using
some things apply from all on-premise
things some things are new some things
are handled by the cloud company so
depending on which security thing you
are referring to you either have and
need to learn of how to update and fly
security patches to your operating
system how to create scripts that stand
for security flows automatically your
applications or how to create security
so so to create an application that
passes a lot of security features for
instance Google Cloud has action on
actual app that will scan your
application for security flow so they
have coded a lot of security holes that
usual web application have and they just
run it each time you deploy any new
version of that app and from what I'm
from what I know this is the best way of
achieving the best security is by
creating automatic scripts that check
for security holes in your application
no matter what if they are installed as
a virtual on virtual machine inside the
container and or a web app or something
else so the best way of addressing
security in the cloud from my opinion is
to create automatic scripts
that that you can check again and again
each time you change your application
and not just a time you de plana a new
version of application you start to
check ok let's see if you can do that or
let's see if you can do that and things
like that so in terms of certifications
for security from what I know Google
doesn't offer any certifications for it
so there are no Google certifications
for security from what I know I might be
wrong but a lot of companies are
focusing just on security or and on
cloud security and on things like that
so you can learn from those next
question any P P request is for ongoing
certificates so depending on the
certificate you are talking about some
of them require you to be sysadmin or
co-ops or a big data specialist or big
business intelligence guy or someone
does that does architecture for
applications or a developer or things
like that so the certifications usually
require you to be one of those guys and
have some experience using those
particular technologies my
recommendation is to have somewhere
between six months and one year of
experience using those technologies
before trying to get a certificate
because certifications are not easy to
obtain because they actually count a lot
when you are you hire somebody
so usually require
for certifications are minimum of sixth
one year of experience plus you doing a
lot of learning about those technologies
not just how much you need it for for
work or things like that so the last
question I have here is does Google
cloud reside on mainframe computer so
Google cloud is actually using a lot of
data centers so Google has developed a
lot of infrastructure for its personal
use to be able to host Gmail and Google
search and YouTube and Google Drive and
applications that he provided for the
users and he just opened up those in
that infrastructure to all of us as
developers to be able to create apps and
do things like that in terms of what
Google cloud actually lives on
they are the data centers that have a
lot of really specialized infrastructure
so specialized CPUs Ram hard drives
tapes and things like that and they are
using a lot of virtualization to be able
to do for one security because I as a
user of cloud I am NOT allowed to be
able to access somebody else's data so
Google does a lot of things in terms of
security that should be done in when
doing public cloud
but mostly they have really fast really
big data centers there that are really
optimized for performance reliability
and cost and they are doing this so that
you can provide great apps for your
users and have something reliable to use
okay so I think that was will last
question if you have any more questions
please post them in the chat room if not
I will give it up to a bead and I would
like to thank you all for attending this
session and asking questions so I would
like to thank you all and a bit if you
have any any things to add please go
ahead okay so I think it doesn't have
any more things to add I would like to
thank you all and hope you enjoyed the
session and the presentation hope you
learned a lot and I managed to convince
you to go for getting certified in cloud
because especially in Google cloud
because this is a great way of
developing skills and it's a thing for
the future so you will be up-to-date on
all those companies that haven't
actually moved to the cloud but that
will do it soon like I said thank you
all and have a great evening
you